newsroom has been getting many questions
about how to get notified when it's your
turn
to get vaccinated eight news now has you
covered the first step is very easy
simply log on to eightnewsnow.com and
it's one of our top five stories right
there you click
on the first story right here to get all
the information on
the covet 19 vaccine all the information
right there is constantly updated from
our web team
including all the information from the
governor's new plan
for the vaccination the next step is to
find out exactly when you will get
vaccinated you need to fill out
a vaccine interest form that link is on
our website and it will take you to the
state's website
right there it will ask you for two in
two questions
if you're an employer or an individual
if you mark that you are an individual
it will ask you for a couple more
questions and right there
you will submit your information for
your name your county the zip code
obviously your phone and email so they
can get a hold of you finally
it will ask you to select your age and
the best category that describes
your health once all that is submitted
you just hit submit
on that button and you wait until
someone will contact you to get
vaccinated now all this information is
available right now on our website
eightnewsnow.com